il y a sauva-t-elle l'humanité nous le
savons l'intelligence artificielle a le
potentiel d'apporter de nombreux
avantages à l'humanité mais elle
présente également des risques et des
défis majeurs pour notre société la
protection de la vie privée la sécurité
les dérives potentiels autant de
préoccupations ethiques qui nous hante
vous vous souvenez de Cambridge
Analytica ces experts de l'IA ont
manipulé les élections présidentielles
grâce à l'espionnage et à des publicités
ciblées effrayant en Espa mais ne soyons
pas définitifs pour autant réunis autour
d'une table ronde avec notre partenaire
et séparis nous avons trouvé une lueur
d'optimisme lia peut être notre allié si
nous la magnions avec sagesse vous
pouvez suivre les échanges qu'on a eu
lors de cette conférence avec le lien
directement en description l'avenir de
l'IA et son impact sur l'humanité dépend
des décisions que nous prenons en
appliquant les sciences et les
techniques par des gens calés et
éthiques on a un vrai moyen de
construire le monde qu'on veut si nous
parvenons à gérer les risques et à
utiliser l'IA de manière responsable
elle pourrait jouer un rôle important
dans la résolution de nombreux problèmes
mondiaux donc je vous le demande